[Music]
it's tactics time
let's take a look here um i'm not
showing that the rating on screen today
because it's just too difficult i can't
do it but for those of you curious
we are currently rated 28.95
so five rating points away five rating
points away
from the promised land of the 2900s i
don't know if we've ever been there
i don't know if we've ever been there i
should actually check let me check on
our profile here
have we ever been to 2900 uh i know we
weren't before today
maybe maybe uh talia did manage to cross
it earlier today
and then got one wrong i'm not entirely
certain but anyways
we're hoping to get back to the promised
land of 2900 we'll see if we can do it
uh up first is the daily puzzle so let's
take a look
uh it looks like probably we should be
trying
to checkmate this king i say that
because it looks pretty airy
and we could probably do something
like uh some sort of attack like this
and and
try and deliver checkmate right the
black major pieces are pretty far away
and that looks pretty strong so sad you
missed the queen's gamut stream you can
go back and watch it hopefully
hopefully the vod is just as good um
it was a lot of fun we actually got a
lot of viewers more viewers than i
anticipated more viewers than ever
before actually
uh so really cool stuff i thought the
craze was over i thought that the people
had had enough
queen's gambit content i thought they
were done
but no they crave more they crave more
anyways this is the daily puzzle so this
one's supposed to be really easy
but it's not it's difficult and that's
just not okay that's
that's actually quite sad i think rook
d8 is correct though
why is rick d8 correct because how do
you stop me from going queen eight and
check meeting you i don't know
why is this not mate in two
i don't know beth versus borgoth oh well
which one there's like three right
or two i don't know i'm gonna level with
you guys
i watched the first three four episodes
pretty diligently i was like
focused paying attention the whole time
episodes five six
and then i sort of tuned back in for for
the last episodes but um
there was a period in the middle there
where i sort of lost focus a bit
nothing to do with the the show being
bad or anything i just
don't have an attention span anymore
anyways the move is clearly rooted to d8
what are we doing here rook d8
that's not it try something else minus
38 is that true
is that true they really got me they
really got me with the daily puzzle i
thought it was the daily puzzle i
thought i couldn't lose rating on the
daily puzzle
telling me i'm losing rating on the
puzzle of the day now
that's new that's new losing rating on
the puzzling on the puzzle of the day
i didn't think you could do that i
didn't think you lost rating on the
puzzle of the day
but clearly i was wrong clearly you do
lose rating on the puzzle of the day
well
that's going to make life a little bit
tougher isn't it that's going to make
life a little bit tougher
um why was rick d8 incorrect
because rook e6 yeah i could have found
that if i like really really tried
but i thought it was the daily puzzle i
didn't think you lost a rating on the
daily puzzle
clearly i was wrong that is new with the
update
well we've got you know 43 points to
gain if we want to get to uh 2 900 then
just have to stop messing up
okay what's going on here this is my
bread and butter king and pawn end games
we go king d6 they play a5 check
or a7 let's say a7 i take it
they go king c5 i come up and
take this guy they go king b4
go king b6 they go a5
i go king a6 they go king a4
i don't know that i'm making the most
progress there i could play something
like d4
they take it i push king b3 king takes
a5 but then i think
they have d5 and i'm not actually in
time to stop this pawn from queening
awkward awkward awkward awkward
okay so king b6 a7 takes king c5 king a6
king b4 i go king b6
if they go a5 check i play not
king a4 i play king a6 and then they are
forced to play something awkward like
king a4
and i can box them out go
and collect this a pawn and then use
this extra tempo here
to to win the game so that looks pretty
good king b6 looks pretty good
daily puzzles are now fitting to the
rating i don't know i don't know the
answer but all i know is i just lost 38
reading points on the daily puzzle which
i did not think was possible
anyways king b6 a7 i think i've now
calculated out to actually just be when
let's just make sure though let's say a5
check i take
the pawn king c5 i take this guy
king back to d4 i go king a4
go collect this pawn that seems pretty
good right seems pretty good
am i not feeling cold today no i'm
feeling all right here in the studio
it's not too bad
i i did wear a coat for the outdoors if
you were wondering
i'm not a maniac all right let's take a
look
a5 check king takes a6 king c5 let's say
takes on a5
and they go crazy they with king king to
d6 i have to play d4
and then what and then what if takes i
go c3 if takes i go c2
and queen easily if takes i take
on c3 queen easily and win the game
that looks pretty good right that looks
pretty good so let's say they
you know take it calm they they're super
calm super collected and they just keep
the king
king around yeah that's just also
clearly losing
uh why doesn't king c6 win probably
because a5
is a good chess move so king b6 it is
best move keep going have to take this
pawn
and now if i'm not mistaken i should be
able to just play king a6
and win the game king d6 again we have
this line that i was talking about
if king b4 i play king b6
and this should also be good enough
best move should be king b6 now if i'm
not mistaken
it would be a bit too early to play g6
because then a5 would force my king back
and i don't actually see how i make
progress but king b6 should get the job
done
okay a5 and i thought king to c6
should be the move that's what i thought
king c6 a6 king b6 a7
take king a5 i can play d4 if king
c5 i can play uh king b7
king b5 i can play g6
if kc5 i can play k6 and again force
this king back
so king c6 it is success and yeah just
to show you guys that line
a6 i think this is the best try
and then the point is even if white is
able to take the opposition it's not
going to make a difference
i just go here oh i can actually play
king a6 right away
but the point is they can't play king a5
because i play d4
and they're not in the circle and if
they try to keep the opposition
i can play g6 here i think
and wrap my way into position
and this of course is easily winning my
king comes to take all the pawns
black white has to deal with this one
and i win all right
see you adi see you on friday i guess as
he said
up next we've gained five of our points
back
this one looks like bishop c4 i'll be
very very surprised
if it is not bishop c4 actually i
am now under the impression that it's
take on d5 take on d5
bishop takes a6 so how do you notice a
thing like that
well there is something you should start
including in sort of your tactical sweep
of the position
i normally talk about loose pieces in a
weak king
but really far advanced pawns are
actually also a thing
you should very much consider in this
case the winning idea
i think is to simply trade off the
queens and then take on a6 and there's
simply no way to stop the b-pawn
from uh from becoming a queen and that
looks pretty good
problem with bishop c4 is black probably
just takes on a5
and then i get to take f7 but like so
what so what
right so what i'm pretty confident in
this one
actually sorry i'm gonna play it
take this guy and i win plus four easy
next okay we get g3
this one looks like i should try to play
for uh
some kind of checkmates
some kind of checkmates alternatively i
could actually take on d1 take on d1 and
take on h2
if king takes h2 i can check
kg2 i could take sorry excuse me
but i think the problem is my rook on a8
is actually just hanging so maybe that's
not so good
maybe that's not so good after all
all right what else can we do what else
can we do
i don't know this one's tough this one's
a bit tough
so yeah queen h5 playing for checkmate
what's the problem the problem i guess
is the move h4 when i don't immediately
see
how to uh checkmate the king
not immediately actually upon further
review it looks as though rick takes d1
rick takes d1 and queen f6
is actually a double attack on white's
weak pieces
and that's probably going to be good
enough i'm attacking
f2 you don't have time to move the
bishop even to take my rook on a8
because queen takes f2 to h2 is
checkmate
and you can't defend both f2 and your
bishop
if you defend f2 then i take the bishop
and honestly that looks quite good
i suppose the last question is what
happens on rook takes d1
and bishop takes on a8
what happens here rook takes d1 bishop
takes a8
i can play rook takes f1 king takes f1
and then what then what do i do i have
queen a1 check my opponent can play king
to g2
not making too much progress
maybe i should change my move order
maybe i should go rook takes d1
bishop takes a8 and then queen a1
directly
and the point now is that i'm
threatening to win a rook and if you
take my rook
i take back with check king h king g2
queen f3 check you have to run up knight
takes f2 check
king h4 and i think the simplest
is queen h5 me that looks pretty good
that looks pretty good why not queen f6
first
uh the reason for that would probably be
rook takes d8 with check
rook takes d8 and bishop takes e4 when
this guy is defended
so rook takes d1 it is
rick takes d1 played in the game and
this one looks like queen f6
and free bishop uh can't you just made
him i i think so the problem is
that's uh after bishop takes a8 i think
after rook takes f1
it's probably yeah it's it's just
equality this isn't checkmate
this isn't checkmate at all
we can defend but the best move it looks
like
is in fact queen a1 apparently quinn f6
is also good but queen a1 makes the most
sense to me
and the point now is that you can't save
this rook because this one
is going to be checkmate
or back check
me pretty good stuff
pretty good puzzle all right easy next
we've made 13 points of the 38 we lost
back
i always got to get the first one wrong
that's what you meant yeah okay all
right that's
easy for you to say all right this is
another confusing puzzle because it
looks too
easy looks like i should play rook c8
check and then make a big
queen and win the game that's what i
would like to do
so why not do that i don't know
i do not know maybe there's some kind of
threat
maybe a lot of people play bishop takes
first and this is wrong because after
rook takes rook c8 king g7
i actually don't have time to queen
because i get checkmated
why is the penalty eight times the
reward uh so we're trying to get 2 900
tonight
uh and the problem is you can
so the way that the puzzle rating system
works is that you have a rating and our
rating is like 2870 or something
and all the puzzles have a rating if you
get the puzzle right
then your rating goes up the puzzle
rating goes down and if you get the
puzzle wrong your rating goes down
puzzle rating goes up so the puzzles
tend to cap out around 2500 sometimes
you'll get some that are a little bit
higher
most times you get some that are a
little bit lower but the puzzles now are
just consistently
a lot lower rated than our account so we
have to get a lot more of them right
in order to gain rating have to be
consistent anyways the answer to this
one
is quite clearly ripped check and now
again i think this would be a mistake
because after rook takes i
don't have a good way to stop the
checkmate
so i'm thinking i should make a big
queen here
and after the move bishop takes b6 i
play a check
either on f8 or h8 and the king moves
and then i take this rook
simultaneously stopping the back rank
mate
this seems to be good enough for me
but maybe if i play queens then rook
takes b6
is a better try uh what's the point the
point is now i can't
sort of do my funny check business to
get out of a threat because
rook b1 is difficult to stop i could
still check on d4
but does this make a difference maybe
not
maybe not
so what do i do do i go rook takes a8s
maybe i go rook takes a 8 here that's
actually a really cool puzzle if rick
takes 8 is the answer because i would
not expect this
i would not expect this
hello to salta salt saltovka
sultovka definitely
all right maybe it's rook takes a8 here
because if i queen i think rook takes b6
might actually be
a pretty good chess move so rook takes a
what is the point
well the point now is that if you play
bishop takes b6
uh i take the rook if you play rook
takes a8s
i take the bishop no this doesn't even
remotely work still rick takes a5 and
this doesn't work at all
none of that works i check on d4 and
then ctrl b1 after that the problem is i
don't control b1 from this square
see that's not how queens move
this puzzle feels familiar it sort of
does doesn't it
sort of does
does feel a bit familiar
craig jennings says everything twice
makes sense okay
move my queen to control b1 uh the
problem then is that you know what black
is just taking on c8 and they have
a lot of rooks and a bishop in exchange
for my queen
which is scary so what else can i do
alright let's say i make a queen
rook takes b6 is the big problem so
let's solve this problem
well at the very very least i suppose i
could play queen
takes rook and the point now is bishop
takes rook
and rook takes rook then they have a
bishop and a pawn
and honestly that should probably be
enough to draw the game that should
probably be enough to draw so i don't
think that line is
is correct
so here's what i could do i could make a
queen rick takes b6 i go
queen f8 check forcing the king out to
h6
then i can play queen h8 check forcing
the king out to one of these squares
if king g5 then i think rook c5 is
strong
same if king f5 then i think rook c5 is
also strong
so that leaves the move
of kev6 so queen h a check king e6
sorry i was sort of trying to check
myself as i went along there
uh and maybe this is just fine though
maybe that's a problem
oh and king to either of these squares i
can actually move one of these pawns
with tempo
interestingly to deal with the threat
and then take the free rook so that
would be
that would be good enough so i queen
rook takes b6 queen fa check
king f6 uh queen h8 check
oh that's just the answer okay i go d8
queen
rook takes b6 and then actually i do it
the other way so queen hha check
forces king h6 then queen f8 check
forces the king to the fifth rank
and then i can move one of these pawns
with check giving me time
to take the rook because i am no longer
mated on the back rank that's that's
pretty cool
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
it's a good puzzle i like this one uh
just
to to triple check i queen they take the
rook
and am i winning enough i take they take
here
is that going to be winning enough or do
i have to do better
do i have to do better i don't know
actually
i don't know that it's winning enough if
just rook takes c8 and rook takes bishop
like
do i have enough there
i do have enough because i can i can
insert bishop d4 check keeping this
bishop so this is in fact
winning the game and yeah that's exactly
what it's played which is a shame
because this line is by far
the most boring of the available options
so what we were talking about there is
the main problem is rook takes v6 and
flipping on the computer
yeah there's only one move that actually
wins the game here you have to go queen
h8 check
between f8 check with the point of
forcing the king to the fifth
and then you actually sacrifice the pawn
in order to stop the backrank mate
and give your king a flight score so
really really cool puzzle
uh it's unfortunate that you don't
actually see this line on the board
but uh it's a pretty rare idea you have
to solve
you know a threat of your own with tempo
which is not a rare idea but
something like this is kind of strange
how about queen a1 after queen each a
check so yeah the problem with those
lines is that um
you just don't have enough right you
just don't have enough here
black has all the pieces too many pieces
all right easy next that one was rated
2500 by the way that was a pretty good
one
we're getting some tough puzzles okay
although i think the puzzles are still a
bit underrated so
let's not pat ourselves on the back too
much
uh what to do what to do in this
position
we have something like rick d1 just
makes a threat obviously i'm eyeing up
stuff like this queen c4
this knight makes a pretty bad
impression this bishop actually also
makes a pretty bad impression
so a lot of potential targets to kind of
look at here so what
what's uh what are we focusing on
it'd be great if we could trap this
knight somehow but i'm not convinced
it's possible
also sort of a small threat like f4
attacking a piece might just be met by
f5
sort of attacking a piece back and
giving this knight a square
so i'm not sure the small threats are
going to get done get it done here let's
look at
the most forcing moves like queen to c4
threatening checkmate checkmate's pretty
good
yeah i need the candidates move machine
that i'm used to getting from from the
chatroom they normally just
rapid fire generate all the legal moves
in the position to think about
it's good stuff so queen takes c4 i
think the only move for black has to be
either queen d7 or queen c7 now let's
focus on queen d7 because i don't see a
reason to allow something like queen e6
check
so queen c4 making a threat queen d7
stopping queen f7 and queen c6 makes
sense
right makes sense now your natural
instinct
should probably be to divert this queen
again with something like rook to d1
so let's say rip to d1 and black goes
wild
just takes your free rook like it ain't
no thing what happens then
i have queen e6 check i also queen f7
check i also have queen's c6 check
but none of these actually seem like
they win the chess game
which is kind of unfortunate kind of
unfortunate right
i don't see how those actually win the
chess game
they look nice but i don't think they
win the chess game and we've got
problems as well
rook d1 then our idea this could be the
solution we're looking for
rook d1 and then maybe the queen has no
good squares
although i might argue that
that c7 is a pretty good square we
follow up with queen takes
on c4 with the idea of some queen e6
check
but i'm not convinced this even makes a
legitimate threat anymore
for example d8 we give our check king f8
and black seems to be covering a lot of
the squares
seems to be covering a lot of the
squares
no i'm sorry i have rook takes d8 there
in queen f7 so that's not good
that's not good yeah alexandra's got it
so rook d1 queen c7 queen c4 uh rook d8
fails to queen e7 check uh
sorry queen e6 check if queen is seven
then queen takes c6 then
d7 then some check here gets complicated
but i
i think maybe black can can do better so
queen takes c4
rook takes d8 is by no means forced so
what can
happen instead rook f8 is technically
legal but queen e6 is probably good
enough then because we get this
so maybe this is the the critical line
then
maybe this is the critical line so rook
d1
uh queen c7 queen takes c4 rook d8
queen d queen e6 check queen e7
uh we meet this with queen take c6 then
rook d7
then if queen a8 check black plays
queen d8 or rook d8
but probably queen d8 if i had to guess
and i don't see how i actually win the
chess game to be a hundred percent
honest with you
and maybe rick d8 is better sorry maybe
your date is better
i don't see how i win the chess game
which is tough
i win a c pawn but i don't know if i win
the chess game
so rook d1 queen c7 queen takes c4 has
to be correct there then rook d8
do i have any kind of improvement
on what i was just looking at
we have a great position yeah you are
down some material though
are down a little bit of material and
your king is a little bit unsafe
yeah i mean i'm not saying white's
position isn't great there because it
still might be but it's not uh not so
cut in your eye definitely
rook d1 queen c7 queen c4 rook d8
queen e6 check queen e7
i can play rook takes d8 forcing king
takes d8 there but
this does not seem to help my cause
i can play queen take c6 forcing rook d7
maybe king f8 is actually playable there
as well
and i'm not seeing it i'm not seeing it
h6
sacking the bishop on h6 i think that
actually activates black's pieces i
think rotates h6 is
pretty comfortable for black with g6
coming
f4 and then rook d1 so i i don't know
how that actually changes the position
too significantly
and i think f4 can be met by f5 as i
mentioned a bit earlier
a bit earlier
if we take the bishop they take the
knight and i think black is pretty happy
to be
getting a lot of these squares back like
knight f6 queen f6 queen h4
all this kind of stuff
after queenie six check then queen to g4
going after the knight
so maybe still maybe this is correct but
um
you do have to be a little bit cautious
about the these f5 moves still i think
there's queen takes f5 there but i don't
know
the knight f6
some elaborate idea with the minor
pieces i wouldn't doubt it maybe i go
queen f5 instead
of queen g4 actually
yeah okay so let's let's calculate rook
d1 queen c7 queen c4 rook d8
queen e6 check queen e7 we have to solve
the problem of
our rook on d1 so let's say rook takes
on d8 check
forcing king takes d8 then some move
like queen f5
knight g3 is a legal chess move if i
capture then bishop takes if i capture
again then my own bishop is hanging
could be a problem i do have queen d3
check as an inner meso there
that seems seems pretty good actually
that seems pretty good i think this is
correct i think queen of five here is
just strong
i think it's just strong so
ricky what it is okay okay whoa
so i made almost a really big mistake
there which is i only calculated one
move after rook d1 because it was so
tough to calculate i forgot the black
has other legal moves
but it turns out black has other legal
moves so
rook d1 queen e7 is really
probably the issue with this line this
is probably just the issue with this
line
uh okay which is probably why queen c4
check is
is first or queen c4 is first maybe okay
so rook d1
queen e7 queen takes on c4
maybe black just has the simple move
rook to c8
and it looks ugly but for the moment
things seem to be holding together i
cannot name you
a particular threat that white actually
has in that position
um yeah looks looks strange
but maybe it's good enough and black's
next move is probably just uh to play
this move
f5 i don't see a good way to stop it so
maybe i'm back to queen takes c4 first
jumping back on this strain this train
rather
there you were looking at knight d6
i don't understand knight d6 i will take
it
you'll have to type out the full line
manny i'm not entirely sure where you
mean
okay so queen takes c4 first if queen c7
then we can just do
a simpler version of this line with
queen f5
i think this is perfectly fine although
then maybe knight g3
is an actual idea if i take take i don't
have queen d3
check ah too many problems to solve
too many problems to solve
rook d1 queen e7 queen c4 rook c8 knight
d6
bishop takes d6 rook takes d6
ah okay so the problem there is that
queen f7 is not checkmate
so queen takes d6 is perfectly fine
queen f7 check
i will play king to d8 and accept your
resignation
so rook d1 queen e7 queen c4
and what's and nothing i think
unfortunately is the answer to that
question so
queen c4 queen d7
rook d1 was the initial thought and if
something like
queen c7 queen e7 why black is losing to
either
this stuff or this stuff so queen takes
d1
probably has to be played
then can i deliver some kind
of forcing idea
i don't think i can this is tough this
is tough this is a really tough puzzle
if i go queen c6 check then king e7
defends the rook i go queen b7 check
then queen d7
is defending everything if i go queen f7
checker queen e6 check
uh just king d8 and i can't get on this
file i can't bring in
any of the minor pieces looks like i'm
just
busted there to be honest with you looks
pretty busted
i feel like we're missing something
important yeah the answer
missing the answer
alexandra has the answer
what if knight f2 would just walk the
king up to g4
okay now you've lost me knight f2 after
queen takes c4 to hold
d1 i think it's just a bit too slow like
uh rick
d8 maybe maybe not d8 actually
that would be a mistake maybe this is
just
like right maybe we just do something
like this
and then just play slowly
and just play slowly playing slowly
feels weird
alright guys i have an announcement to
make
after i play queen take c4 why has no
one in the chat realized
that queen to d5 is a legal chess move
how are we all missing this huh i blame
you i blame you
okay i'm allowed to miss stuff but
there's like more of you than there are
of me
there's more of you than there are of me
okay you're embarrassed you should be
embarrassed okay
this is why this is why i rely on you
guys that's why you're here
all right it's queen d5
okay so you're saying that f4 black
response
i was saying f4 black responds with f5
this is the problem
but assuming that you know the chat has
gone ahead
and used an engine by now i'm assuming
there's some problem with this
and the problem is you know we just
retreat right this is probably the issue
just retreat this bishop comes back to
c7 let's say i play queen takes f5
there's knight
to back to f6
and what and what
i don't know to be honest
i don't know f4 f5 i need
something juicy
i could still play queen takes c4 there
there's still queen d5
i could play f takes e4
and then f t or sorry f takes e5 then
there's f takes e4
yeah maybe queen d5 in that line as well
manny
if i play knight f2 bishop c7
yeah f4 we have to solve the problem of
f5 somehow this is the only
the only noticeable issue with playing
f4 here otherwise it's just a great move
otherwise it's just a great move
if knight f5 then queen e6 check queen
e7 then queen c6 check i'm
confused
f4 after the queen e2 line i
don't understand what you mean with
queen e2 knight f6
queenie's six check
king f8 i think cause problem i don't
know queenie i don't know what queen e2
line means
this is the e2 square are you saying
there's some line where this happens
i don't know rook d1 queen e2
queen e7 you mean queen e7 rook d1
queen e7 queen takes c4 rook c8
then f4 then f5
and things have changed for some reason
things have changed for some reason
i don't see why they've changed to be
honest with you do you not see why
they've changed
what is so different
if he takes back then rook d6 and how
does he stop rick e6
okay this is pretty deep stuff here guys
it's pretty deep stuff
maybe he doesn't stop rookie 6 maybe he
doesn't
queen can't go to c7 anymore
no we analyzed queen c7 that move loses
that that move loses because rook d1
queen c7 queen c4 rook d8 queen e6
queen e7 rook d8 king d8
queen f5 and i take this guy for free
that was the claim
that was the claim for why that move
loses by force
but queen e7 was tougher but now we're
saying rook d1
queen e7 queen takes c4
and they try to defend this pawn somehow
the best we could come up with
is rook c8 not rook d8 but rook c8
rather and now the chat is claiming
f4 wins here because if they play f5 we
are capturing on e5 if they capture
on e4 then rook to d6
with point of work to e6 okay
and if king to f eights perhaps
after rook d6 what happens there
it feels like we should win somehow how
do we win
how do we win we could still go rookie
six there's queen takes h4
go rook e8 check then king e8 queen f7
is not
checkmate there's king d8
so rook d6 king f8 it feels like there
should be a win
but i don't necessarily see it
just yet feels like there should be a
win though
queen f7 you'll have to be more specific
it's a move in many of these lines
saying queen f7 trading
the queens i don't think so i don't
think so
the idea is that the queen will be able
to capture the night
wow i hadn't considered that thank god
you're here
all right i'm going to play rook d1
queen e7 queen c4 should be right
there's no reason to not play queen c4
okay just work d8
yeah now this is just uh a bit silly now
it's just queen takes c6
and life is pretty good i think right
life is pretty good
life feels reasonably good
feels reasonably good right i take here
rook to d7 then i can play f4 again
as we were discussing
uh and that should be good enough to win
i think
if f5 then i take on e5
if take on e4 then i play e6 if the
bishop moves
then what then what
yeah then i guess i just trade
everything and go king of three king g4
or something
uh it seems good enough success yeah
that was a tough one that one was rated
25.55
let's see what what happens here here i
was claiming that f4 should be played
which is a winning move but apparently
not as winning as knight c5 or a5 or
b4 here bishop to
eights and my claim was that i could
even get away with this
can i get away with this maybe i can't
get away with this
yeah i don't this puzzle's just too
tough uh let's see what happens
if rook c8 for c8 then f4
not bishop f4 but f4 and then if f5
uh fe5 fv4
rook d6 king f8
and yeah here you just take it's you
know
it's whatever right it's whatever very
tough puzzle
very tough puzzle um
but in the end the sort of the most
natural moves were correct
yeah tough tough one tough one all right
on to the next
on to the next all right we gotta gain
14 more rating points so we got to pick
up the pace a little bit here got to
pick up the pace a little bit
all right what to do i'm white i pretty
much have to checkmate my opponent i
think
or like get queens off the board so i
don't die but that's probably not good
enough even
so how do i do that well if i move my
queen
probably going to get hit by rook b8
mate if i play d6
probably gonna get hit by queen takes d6
at least like a draw
if i play rook h2 does anything bad
happen to me
i don't think so i don't think anything
bad happens to me i'm making a very very
clear threat
i don't see how my opponent stops it i
guess they play king
to f5 then that surely
will run into a checkmate play queen h7
check
if king e5 i play queen e7 check
king 2 back to f5 i have 26 of king
f4
maybe i just take this rook for free
probably i do
okay so rook h2 king f5 check if the
immediate king f4
what happens there what happens on the
immediate king f4 i go queen c7 check
and pick up this rook
okay so let's say queen g king g4
then there's queen h5 king f4
and what's and what's just like rook g2
or something i get mated by rick b8
i don't know this is a puzzle where like
rook h2 is almost definitely the answer
but uh the question is
you know why why does it actually work
and that is not
an easy question to uh to answer
has to be rook ht though i'm i'm
honestly pretty tempted to just put it
on the board
king g2 then bishop e2 check king g4 the
bishop to check and the king is forced
to dark squares
bishop v2 check feels highly illegal
feels highly illegal
i could be wrong but that's the feeling
i get
uh king g4 there's queen h3 and maybe
this is better somehow
but maybe not
there's also rook g2
there's also rook g2 rook g2 is probably
the answer against king f4
or king g4 doing some chess tactics just
just some just a few just a few chess
tactics
all right i'm gonna play uh i'm gonna
play rook hitch two
best move keep going give check win game
should be rip g2 here right here g2 king
f4 queen
check mini five take the guy
looks good enough to me rook g2 of king
f3 then queen h3
and black is sort of getting checkmated
sort of probably
probably getting checkmated right
probably
rick g2 king of three queen h3 king f4
queen g4 king here
this check came here
rook chad check king e3
rook check king d2
hey okay all right i'll think about it
i don't see how i'm getting the rook
anymore to be honest with you richie g2
if king f4 then i play queen c7 and i
win
uh because you can't stop queen d8 if
you play king f3 there then queen g3 is
mate
rook g2 king f3 then i don't see how i
went
i don't see how i went i have queen h3
check if king f4 you're saying queen h2
check but
i don't see how that helps queen h2 king
f5
if rook f2 king g6
hello real nanaki zabala
then i have queen h7
don't see okay
yes that is good enough all right richie
who it is
success plus one really good puzzle okay
hello stuffed pink owl so let's see that
full line so yeah queen of queen h3
check
queen h2 check is actually the only move
that wins which is kind of crazy
and then as stated in the chat give him
the old run around here
and this is mate or i win
this piece which is pretty good
tough puzzle tough puzzle
congratulations
on the uh the perfect game there real
congratulations plus one
tough going these days tough going all
right so far i've lost rating on the
night which is
bad i have five minutes to gain like 13
rating points
which is just not gonna happen uh
that being said bishop e5 looks pretty
good here
bishop b5 does look pretty good there's
queen f3 to try
to defend everything but then maybe i
have some cleverly timed rick takes b2
maybe i have rick takes b2
in this position but maybe
not that is the question
we must ask ourselves so rook takes b2
rook takes b2 queen takes g3 king to h1
and i don't see the continuation i like
i can take this
knight i can give a check but then
there's rick h2
don't see the victory just yet don't see
the victory just yet
so what else what else go rook b4 make a
threat
b4 certainly does make a threat
there's knight f3
there's also like rook a to g1 or
something
knight g6 check i don't think quite
works because i take with the pawn and
then the queen is attacked
but i think rook takes p2 is fine
honestly
we have bishop takes then we're hitting
the rook threatening mate i don't see
how we're threatening mate after bishop
takes or bishop takes to be honest with
you
ah you're saying rook takes rook takes
and then bishop takes hitting the
threatening mate but rook to g1 there
is perhaps a legal chess move to solve
both problems
i'm still sort of drawn to this bishop
e5 idea
somehow i'm drawn to this idea but i
don't think so
it's made in one queen takes rook i
disagree i think there's a g pawn in the
way
i think this g pawn is still here rook
takes pawn rook
takes bishop takes rook g1 defending the
g
pawn
we already took ah you're saying take g3
first okay
rook takes rick takes takes king h1
bishop takes attacking the rook
threatening queen h3
how to solve all z problems i
i don't see it to be honest so rook
takes b2 rook takes b2 is out
what else can be done rook over here
could be done
but then i check check mate
so rook takes what else can be done
queen f3 can be done
but then perhaps i take this guy
and you can't take back so the pin you
can't take my rooks i take the check
looks pretty good
i take here and take here
i've been checked honestly i'm
devastated
yeah so now the problem is h takes is no
longer good
because of queen h6 mate so probably i
have to go rook takes
which is seemingly still okay i think i
just end up with an extra piece
there's no funny forks because this
bishop is so far away from my king
and plus one easy next
easy plus ones okay
and this might actually have to be the
last puzzle of the stream which isn't a
shame because i've i've lost reading on
the night with that minus 38.
real tough real tough okay 96 looks
pretty strong right
96 looks pretty strong bishop takes g7
potentially also looks really strong
maybe stronger maybe this is stronger do
i see a mate
do i see a mate there i don't see a mate
there to be honest with you
96 or bishop g7 or rook or g7 isn't
right so let's say bishop g7
pawn takes on f4 bishop takes on f6 with
check i take a free queen okay that
looks pretty good
that looks pretty good bishop takes on
g7 they take me back i go
rook takes king takes knight e6 i win a
queen
so bishop takes g7 they have to find
something smarter
but i don't think anything smarter
actually exists
so i am going to take this there's
bishop takes on f2
king takes on f2 knight g4 rook takes on
g4
rook takes on f4 is this something to
worry about
maybe that's something to worry about
sorry i lost rating i'm not actually too
upset about it to be honest with you
but we are not going to make it to the
promised land of 2500 or 2900
king h8 well then then you're down on
rook but um
bishop takes g7 i'm guessing bishop
takes f2
is the idea if i play king takes f2 then
knight g4
check and then i actually think i have
to play queen takes g4 and the point is
if rook takes f4 i take with the queen
uh take and then i go bishop f6 and i
end up upper rook so that seems pretty
good this should win
okay we don't even get to see it maybe i
had something better in that line
actually
but this should be good enough rick
takes g7
so the thing i was pointing out is
bishop f2 king f2
knight g4 check and apparently this is
good enough
yeah still up down a piece at the end of
this and getting mated
but i was saying this is potentially
even better
with this point winning the queen
anyways okay i clicked the next puzzle
we'll solve one more i don't care i'm
already over time
but i'm here anyways so let's just get
it done
let's just get it done should be f3
check because what else what else
besides f3 check right it's not knight
takes e4
it's not some funny move maybe
it's rook h6 but i mean it's
not so who are we kidding here it's got
to be f3 check
gotta be f3 check right what else
if not f3 delivering a check
best move keep going that's the way i
like it
g3 threatening g2
what else what
else g3
queen f3 g2 king e2
i take this or something doesn't quite
work
queen e3 is a legal move
hmm rook f6 is a legal move
if i go g3 queen of three i ever got six
to win the queen
but the question is is is that enough
because i'm already down
a piece and a rook so like i still have
to get more
after that probably i do get more
but uh it's worth noting that i'm not
just completely winning yet
yeah i definitely do get more of those
so this should just be good
i don't think g2 check is correct here
because then king e2
and like i can take this rook for free
but what does that actually do for me
not much just like rook takes and then
the king is actually escaping
so it should be rick f6
and i'll take that and plus three
easy easy one so we're actually ending
up downrating tonight
usually doesn't happen we're only on
minus seven though it's not too bad
it's definitely been worse definitely
been worse
but let's go ahead and give somebody a
raid and get out of here for the night
i've had my fair share of chess looks
like we're reading
good old bobby hess fun stuff
so go check out robert hess uh he runs a
good stream and streams quite often i
think
that's it from us here tonight hopefully
you enjoyed the lectures if you missed
it on youtube i did
a beth harmon bandwagon uh
chess lecture going over some really fun
openings from the show
so do check that one out if you're
curious otherwise
that's it for me tonight as always my
name is caleb denby and i will see you
next time